when Zach wrote that part for you I mean
did he let you know that he's writing it
for you did he let you know like yeah
you're going to act in my show and how
did you feel well when he first called
me about it he just left me a voicemail
and I couldn't tell what it I thought
maybe he was gonna do a late night
appearance and wanted me to do a bit
with him because he had asked me to do
that before and I said no because it
seemed embarrassing
Zach loves being embarrassed like he
thinks it's funny if if he looks
ridiculous and I don't have the the
healthy inner
self-esteem that he has so that's what I
thought it was and then when we finally
talked he said
it's a pilot for FX I'm gonna play a um
a rodeo clown who lives in a motel in
Bakersfield I would like you to play my
personal assistant and I thought like
and I said like well I don't I don't
think I can act like if
it's you know uh
I hadn't had a couple of meetings with
casting directors after
in 20 in 2002 I did Montreal and it and
it went well the Comedy Festival did
people get jobs from yeah and then I had
meetings with casting directors and they
were all it was terrible and I was like
I'm gonna freeze up like I did for that
I'm not gonna be able to do this and he
said it doesn't matter it's not
important it's just fun just say your
lines like you would say anything as
yourself
and I was like I'm still not gonna be
able to do it but at least it would be
a little bit of again it would be money
and I knew Zach if he had to fire me he
would be as kind as possible about it
and I thought I have to try it I can't
not try it yeah so that's how it started
and then when they got the um order for
the rest of the season it was like but
it changed into being a Costco car
insurance person not his because it
didn't make sense for a rodeo clown to
have a personal assistant well the show
didn't make sense it didn't really fine
but yeah yeah but it was like
just getting to spend hours a day
sitting next to Zach yes just always
feeling he's always likes uh emotionally
balanced person to be with in addition
to being super funny yeah so it was a
combination of like I always feel
relaxed and safe with him and he makes
me laugh all the time yeah and he's
truly one of the he's a magical person I
love him so much me too yeah and I love
being around him and you know
you know we've gotten to be friends over
the years like you know I don't I don't
do anything I don't go out with anyone
but I go out to dinner with Zach you
know like yes because
I said I love him so much he's a dear
person yeah for sure very special too
yeah